how did you become involved in science
if you go back to thank for me it was it
was probably goes back to a teacher in
junior high middle school who is who is
an outstanding it was an outstanding
teacher and really started challenging
me and getting me interested in science
and so it continued from there it took
many different variations along the way
until I arrived at chemistry but it was
still always a science science emphasis
and that's a shock but I've always been
curious about things and interested in
making things and I still work a lot
with my hands and woodworking and so on
so when I was maybe eight years old my
second oldest brother Ted gave me what
we call the proverbial chemistry set and
so that got me interested in chemistry I
decided to channel my efforts in that
direction and never really changed I
kept with chemistry more or less sounds
like then dangerous thing to get the
chemistry set to put it in the hands of
this child
well back then they were they were
pretty good things a lot of stuff no
accidents I wouldn't say no that's what
keeps you in chemistry as the explosion
is the accidents